das klima selbstversorgung in der stadt
ist ein ganz ganz kleiner ausschnitt
einer sehr sehr großen frage wir wollen
das ganze ein bisschen runterbrechen in
diesem kleinen projekt auf die
mikroebene sozusagen und in den keller
hinabsteigen und da schauen wie viel
kann man denn da anbauen kann man da was
anbauen unter welchen bedingungen und
machen
es ist speziell sein zelt ein großzelt
das ist sehr verbreitet
hauptsächlich für den cannabisanbau im
keller
ja das ist die illegale nutzung daher
kommt die technologie und die nutzen wir
jetzt auf legalem wege für uns
das heißt wir gehen her und benutzen
dieses zelt und gemüse anzubauen im
keller die lampe die ist sehr stark
also ich brauch relativ viel licht um
die pflanzen groß zu ziehen und auch die
belüftungsanlage das braucht strom
wir brauchen am tag ungefähr 30 cent
strom
das klingt jetzt nicht viel aber wenn
ich das über 100 tage rechnen dann sind
dann 30 euro weg und wie viel salat kann
ich für 30 euro kaufen steht dann dem
entgegen
[Musik]
ja wir haben das jetzt hier aufgebaut
das kleine gewächshaus und man sieht
schon bei der frage in welchem umfang
können wir uns in der stadt selber nie
an oder als selbstversorger was unsere
ernährung beitragen das ist jetzt hier
wirklich eine micro lösungen der
kellergewölbe keller eines altbaus ganz
typisch für die stadt
wie gut dass ein bisschen kraft jetzt
wird ein kleines loch in die mitte
gemacht
setzlinge die erpresst werden ebenerdig
eingesetzt ist nicht zu tiefe nicht so
genau so wie es jetzt aussieht
[Musik]
achtung gleich erzählt
man sieht egal ob die pflanzen grün oder
braun waren vorher dass sie jetzt braun
leuchten weil sie normalerweise das
grüne licht nur reflektieren alles
andere wird absorbiert das licht was
jetzt hier von der lampe kommt ist nur
rot und blau
da sind überhaupt keine grün anteile
drin die reflektiert werden können
johanna bekommen licht und viel licht
hier oben brauche ich nicht ich brauche
da unten dazu gemacht mal schauen wie
das jetzt wird und wie das dann auch
schmeckt wenn es was wird zwei monate
müssen wir ungefähr warten und ich bin
ziemlich gespannt
[Musik]